MODERATOR: All right, everybody.
I hope you all had
a good morning today
and enjoyed your lunch.
Thanks for joining us today.
I'm very happy to be moderating
a GCP Partner Panel, where
we have four industry
experts who are here
to talk to us a
little bit about some
of the practical strategies
they've had helping customers
move to the cloud.
A quick round of introductions.
To your left is Mike Pearl.
Mike is a principal at PwC's
US Consulting business.
Mike is PwC's Technology
Consulting Leader
for the Technology,
Entertainment and Media,
Telecommunications, and
Hospitality industries.
He also serves as PwC's
Global Cloud Computing Leader.
Mike has been a leader in
PwC's digital transformation
initiatives for
several years, and was
one of the principal
authors of the firm's
digital transformation framework
in cloud computing strategy.
Mike has over 22 years of
management and technology
consulting experience,
delivering strategy, design,
and operations
consulting, as well
as large-scale transformation
in technology services
to clients across
multiple industries.
Welcome, Mike.
MIKE PEARL: Thank you.
MODERATOR: Next, we
have John Crosthwait.
John is Accenture's CTO for
the Communications, Media,
and Technology sector.
Based in LA, John has spent 25
years working in the industry,
and has-- for the
past 10 years--
been responsible for Accenture's
largest media clients,
including the Walt
Disney Company.
As the North
American CTO for CMT,
John leads technology
consulting,
which drives Accenture's broad
offerings-- spanning strategy,
consulting, technology,
operations, and digital--
to create end-to-end
transformation on how clients
deliver technology in this
rapidly-evolving market.
John is also responsible for
Accenture's digital video
practice, which serves media,
cable, and telecom companies
to launch, evolve,
and operate product
in this
progressively-disrupted market.
Thanks, John.
JOHN CROSTHWAIT:
Good to be here.
MODERATOR: Next,
we have Mike Kavis.
Mike is the Vice President
and Principal Architect
at Cloud Technology Partners.
Mike is a distinguished author
of "Architecting the Cloud,"
and writes for both "Forbes" and
"The Virtualization Practice."
Mike has held various positions
such as CTO, Chief Architect,
and VP of Architecture.
His current focus areas are
IoT, big data, and containers.
And finally-- last but not
least-- we have Uday Ayyagari.
Uday is the Chief Solutions
Architect and Google Alliance
Solutions Head at Tech Mahindra.
With over 20 years of experience
and executive leadership,
he owns a large
solutions portfolio
across a number of verticals.
Uday has built several large
delivery teams and innovation
centers, and focuses
on strategic adoption
of cloud and IoT.
Please help me in
joining our panel.
[APPLAUSE]
So Mike, starting
with you, can you just
tell us a little bit
more-- introduce your firm
and tell us a little bit
about your areas of expertise,
and how you've helped
companies move to the cloud?
MIKE PEARL: Sure,
so happy to be here.
People probably
recognize the PwC brand--
the largest
professional services
firm in the world across
accounting, tax, and advisory
business.
And as part of our
advisory business--
I'm a partner in our
we have consulting deals
and our forensics teams,
but within consulting
we focus quite a lot
on large-scale business
transformation.
Several years ago I was asked
to lead our cloud efforts.
And when we look
at cloud computing,
we look at it very
holistically across what
it's doing for an enterprise--
both within their IT
organization, in their
product organization--
and how organizations
are leveraging cloud
to drive productivity
and transformation
within particular
business units.
And I'm based here
in the Bay Area,
and so we focus a lot on our
high-tech and now broader
set of clients, on transforming
how new services and products
that they can develop
using cloud technology
to deliver to their customers.
So a broad range
of things, and I'm
sure we'll get into
some of the discussions
on specific details.
One of the interesting
things here
is PwC-- we migrated away
from our legacy workplace
productivity tools over
to Google for Work.
And now I'm leading a
number of initiatives
and developing
tools and solutions
on top of the Google
Cloud platform
that we're delivering
to our clients.
MODERATOR: Great, thank you.
John, can you talk
for Accenture?
JOHN CROSTHWAIT: I'm
glad to be here as well.
Most of you may have heard
of Accenture as well, much
like PwC.
We're a large global
management consulting firm,
we have about 400,000
resources around the world.
And we're really
organized resource-wise
around two key dimensions--
one is capability.
All of our consultants
have a deep acumen
in a particular
capability, whether it's
strategy, consulting,
operations, digital,
or technology.
And what we've found in
addressing large enterprise
cloud transformation is that
each of these capabilities
play a very key role in a
successful transformation--
whether you're defining
the vision in the roadmap,
standing up a particular
cloud implementation,
or designing an op model on how
we organize resources ongoing.
The other dimension is industry.
And industry dictates where we
have individuals support which
clients.
And while most of
the considerations
we look at in considering
a cloud journey
are broadly applicable
across the market,
we do find that there
is some industry
nuance that can affect any
individual company's cloud
journey.
So for example in
media, we might
find that we start in the
digital media workflow space,
or with a large
telco we might start
with their omnichannel
platform and the like.
All of our customers
are consuming
cloud today, whether it's
individual, SaaS, products,
platforms like GCP
where they're building
custom applications and
the like, or buying storage
and compute.
And we've found that
about 80% of all companies
are using infrastructure as a
service to some degree today,
and the result of this
pattern of consumption
is really these
hybrid environments.
And we've found about
50% of all companies
have hybrid cloud
strategies, and we
think that is a
blueprint that is going
to continue into the future.
And it's guided
how we've invested
in our cloud capability,
in serving the market.
A couple of examples, I guess.
We have an organization
called Cloud First, where
we house about 21,000
skilled resources
on a broad set of leading
cloud platforms and products.
And we've spent years and
considerable R&D resources
in developing something
called the Accenture Cloud
Platform, which is an open
multi-vendor platform that
enables organizations to
effectively and efficiently
manage hybrid environments.
So at any rate, I
hope that gives you
a little bit of insight
in how we view the market.
MIKE KAVIS: Mike Kavis
here, I'm glad to be here.
You may've not heard
of us, but we're
Cloud Technology Partners based
out of Boston, Massachusetts.
Our consultants live
everywhere-- I'm out of Tampa.
We're about a
100-person company.
We're the born-in-a-cloud
type company,
so a lot of our people--
including myself--
come from the enterprise.
Some people run data
centers, I myself
have worked on distributed
systems and big data
systems for years.
And our goal is to
accelerate the cloud,
accelerate whether you
move into the cloud
or build the cloud--
whatever you're doing,
we have a lot of IP and
documented processes
of how to get you there
as fast as possible.
And we iterate through things.
So that's our story.
We do everything from cloud
migration, cloud strategy,
to dev ops, to containers,
technologies, you name it.
We cover the broad spectrum.
UDAY AYYAGARI: Hi, my
name is Uday Ayyagari
and I come from Tech Mahindra.
And we are a global
SI for Google,
and we have a very
large practice
in various different
areas of cloud.
We have about 120,000
employees across the globe.
You probably haven't heard
much about Tech Mahindra,
but we are predominantly all
over the globe-- APAC, ANZ,
and the Americas.
And we are engaged actively
in a lot of telecom-- telecom
being one of our
largest sectors.
And then we are heavy
into automobile industry,
several different verticals.
We come with a strong practice
in advisory services, business
transformation projects.
And we have over 50 different
services and product
frameworks.
So the key aspect of our
go-to-market strategy
is to take solutions--
it's basically
a solution-based approach where
we have a number of frameworks
there, including the cloud
migration strategy that we've
going to talk about.
And also we have different
service offerings and product
offerings across the
various different industries
that I talked
about-- predominantly
in analytics and
telecommunications,
telecommunications with
analytics and automobile.
MODERATOR: Great, thanks.
Why don't we do a
quick market survey?
So can you talk a
little bit-- and maybe
we'll start with you, Uday--
on the trends you're seeing?
What are customers trying
to do in the cloud?
And where have they
seen the most success?
UDAY AYYAGARI: Yeah, so
thanks for the question.
So we have noticed
a lot of heavy trend
towards migrating-- basically,
cloud is here to stay.
And there's a lot
of stress on moving
their applications, mostly
the on-premise applications.
One of the forces may be
moving over from the CapEx
to an OpEx model.
The focus is mostly on
getting onto the cloud.
And there's a lot of
confusion and fear
and lack of experience that's
driving a lot of this strategy
towards moving
over to the cloud.
So we are noticing a lot
of movement, so to speak,
like in moving some of the
reporting, the DR applications
over to the cloud.
So that's the primary focus.
MODERATOR: Are you seeing
anything different, Mike?
MIKE KAVIS: Yeah, we're seeing
a lot of movement to the cloud,
both from native development--
but one of the big drivers
is data center consolidation.
So a lot of companies
have 30 and they
need to get to five by x date,
and that's driving the lift
and shift mentality.
We don't have time to
change the architecture,
we just need to get
there, consolidate,
get our expenses down, and
then the next generation
is, how do I modernize
and really take
advantage of the high-level
features of the cloud?
MODERATOR: OK.
John, anything to add?
JOHN CROSTHWAIT: Yeah.
One thing I'd share, I guess,
is that each year Accenture
publishes a technology vision.
We do this to identify what are
the trends that we think are
going to affect our clients
in a significant way,
in an 18-to-36-month
planning horizon?
And one of the themes in
this year's tech vision
was around the platform economy.
And part of this exercise
includes a survey--
we surveyed about 3,500
technology executives
around the world.
And it was
interesting-- about 85%
came back with the
statement that they believe
that their company is going to
move away from selling products
today to selling business
outcomes through managed
services in the next
three to five years.
And we think this is
a trend that's really
going to push traditional
companies to get
into the platform
business, as sort
of their foundational method
of delivering products
and services.
And you can kind of
start to see some of that
show up in the market today.
You've got companies
like General Motors
who's implementing My Chevrolet,
which is a platform that
integrates the buyers of
their electric vehicle--
The Bolt-- to upload car
vehicle performance information,
trend it, benchmark it
against other drivers,
send it to product
development and the like.
Or companies like
Kaiser Permanente,
who's establishing a platform
to collect and manage
electronic medical
data, but also
integrate all the
broad ecosystem
players that help
them collectively
serve their patients today.
Or even General Electric, who's
starting to pivot-- move away
from their traditional
industrial manufacturing roots
and getting more into
software and data.
So we think this
trend will continue.
And as these epicenters in
industries start to mature,
they're going to have to
support millions of consumers,
thousands of ecosystem
partners, operate
in an always-on
environment, which
is going to require them to work
with web-scale large-platform--
trusted platform
providers like Google
and the like going forward.
And I think Google
happens to be one
that is well-positioned to serve
this market in a lot of ways.
We believe in their
proven ability
to look at their
core product and data
and create new, interesting,
value-added services-- much
like the Vision API we saw
earlier in the keynote.
MIKE PEARL: Yeah, I would just
add similarly, at PwC each year
we survey over 1,400-- this
year it was over 1,400 CEOs
globally.
And it's a pretty
broad split of sizes
of organizations, a global
mix across all industries.
And for the fourth
year in a row,
the number one item
top-of-mind for CEOs
was the impact
technology is going
to have on their business.
And both from the
perspective of how
are they going to
leverage new technologies
to create a
competitive advantage,
but also a concern about smaller
organizations that have access
to platforms like the
Google Cloud platform
that can quickly take IP and
create solutions and really
disrupt what our clients are
trying to do in the market.
And so a lot of
the trend that we
see from that-- and actually,
interestingly enough this year
there was a bit of a pivot.
It's not just about
the technology,
but how is that technology being
leveraged to drive innovation,
and innovation with
respect to product,
with respect to how they're
operating their business?
And this unique
kind of interplay
between how technology gets
leveraged for innovation
and how you're going to
leverage and identify talent
to allow you to do that.
And it's really all with respect
to moving faster in an ever
more dynamic marketplace.
And so for instance,
we-- working with Google
and on the Google Cloud
platform-- one of the things
that we thought was very
important was to-- the number
one item that comes
up is around security
is to really take
that head-on, where
we've developed our security
analytics platform leveraging
the Google Cloud
platform with this notion
that security of exclusion
is really a bit of a myth.
You're always compromised
at some level.
And so the goal is,
how quickly can you
identify what's happening
within your environment,
pinpoint where it is,
and remediate that?
And so that's just an
example, similar to what
we're seeing with in our
survey at our clients.
But really starting to
look at, how can you
leverage this
technology to create
something that is differentiated
for you in the market?
MODERATOR: You know I appreciate
you, Mike, for bringing up
security.
I think one of the
themes that we just
heard is sort of this
opportunity that's
afforded by technology
and by cloud,
but also the business
transformation that's
happening, and the uncertainty,
and some of the fear that
revolves around that.
So can you talk a little
bit to some of the hurdles
that you're seeing
companies face,
and what you guys
are doing to help
them overcome those hurdles?
MIKE PEARL: Yeah,
well when you think
about conservative
organizations,
our brand is relatively
conservative.
So we spent-- and I was
up close and personal
when we made our decision to
move over to the Google Cloud
platform and Google for Work.
There was a lot of
questions, understandably,
because we're in a regulated
environment, our audit
business.
And a lot of questions
around security
and how we would manage that.
And working with Google,
we were able to get
through the security questions.
But the biggest thing
that we're seeing
is, quite frankly,
regulation compliance.
And regulation understandably
isn't keeping pace
with the rate of
change in technology.
And so oftentimes where there
is amazing technology that
allows organizations
to connect better,
move faster in the market,
there are regulations
that were written
many years ago that
didn't contemplate the
technologies that are there
today.
And so a lot of what we
spend time with our clients
helping them work
with is understanding
what those regulations
are, understanding
how they can apply
those regulations--
in the context of
some of the hurdles
that we would see-- apply those
regulations in understanding
how they can still get
benefit from the technology.
MODERATOR: Got it.
Great.
John, are you seeing
anything different?
JOHN CROSTHWAIT: You know,
you mentioned security.
The only thing
I'd add to that is
that definitely with all
the cyber breaches recently,
that's obviously created
a lot of anxiety.
One pattern we have
seen is that as clients
get closer to the providers
that they've selected,
like a Google, they
inevitably push through it.
And I think it's more about just
engaging with the right vendors
that you trust.
And at the end of the day,
public cloud consumption
is rising at 44% a year right
now, and on premise at 9%.
So the move to
public cloud is not
stopping because of security,
but it's obviously always
the first thing.
I think the other
common barrier that we
find is just the mental
barrier of where to start.
It can seem very daunting.
There's a lot of-- do we do
a traditional lift and shift?
Do we new on new?
What is the right approach?
And honestly, the guidance
that we always give
is to really take the time to
put together a cloud strategy
and a vision and a roadmap, and
all the due diligence that that
implies, to allow you
to move with confidence.
Because it really is a
broad transformation.
It's not about procurement
or finding a new hardware
infrastructure provider.
It's a broad transformation
that needs to be
given that level of diligence.
And then I think, lastly,
another hurdle we've seen
is just internal talent.
So as you might guess,
most organizations
don't have a breadth of talent
sitting there that understand
how to design cloud based
architectures in high velocity
environments and the like.
And so as you create your
vision and your roadmap
to roll out cloud capability
within your organization,
having a talent plan that can
keep pace with that roadmap
is crucial.
MODERATOR: Great.
Mike?
MIKE KAVIS: The other
thing is there's
a lot of mythology about cloud
security, stuff like that.
So when of the first
things we do is we come in.
And the first thing
we do is a workshop.
And we kind of go through
all that, talk about myth
versus reality.
And we have a lot
of case studies
of our own clients in financial
institutions and health
institutions that this is how
they overcome those hurdles.
And we have one customer who
was in the security space
when Heartbleed was going on.
Well, how long does it
take you to patch that?
Well, it takes months
to provision a server.
So I kind of drew this chart.
And I said, OK,
over three months,
this is how many Heartbleed
type things happen.
So by the time you get rid of
this one, there's four more.
There's another reason to take
advantage of the cloud, right?
Infrastructures, code.
You can actually turn servers or
VMs around in minutes or days.
So it's kind of leveling
the playing field.
There's a lot of chatter.
And a lot of it
comes from companies
that are not benefiting
from the public cloud.
Hardware companies,
private cloud companies.
So it's a leveling
the playing field,
showing real use cases
of real success stories.
Just kind of
leveling the playing.
UDAY AYYAGARI: You know,
so from our perspective,
when we go to a
client-- typically,
nine out of 10 cases, it's
basically the security.
Security is job
number one always.
And we've talked
enough about that.
However, we need to--
part of the methodology
and the framework that
we offer, on a side note,
is we have a complete,
fully mature framework where
we have-- we went to the
client and understand
what this security
architecture is currently,
what the security assets
are, and move them over
to the new platform.
But it's not as simple as like
just doing the lift and shift.
So security one side.
Now we have-- that needs
to be, basically, addressed
with performance.
Security performance, and
then we have loss of control.
So there's a perception
among the customer community
about losing all
this infrastructure.
They've invested
already heavily into it.
What are they going
to do about it?
So sometimes it's
a balancing act.
It's not a
straightforward answer.
It's a one-size-fits-all
does not work out here.
They need to weigh their
options on is it, like,
do they move now?
Is it the right time to
move over to cloud and adopt
the best cloud practices?
Because it's an imperative.
I mean, it's not a joke
question of choice.
As against, do they
want to still hold
on to their infrastructure and
the investments that they have.
So there's a loss of
control I was talking about.
Now the other aspect,
which is slightly tougher,
is what we face is
the business aspect.
So we have changed management.
There's this whole perception
about loss of jobs.
I mean, what traditionally used
to be the hard jobs that we
talked about in a moment back,
they could be transformed.
So how do we retrain,
reskill workers?
How does the management
look at that?
So there's various
different aspects to it.
Now part of that also goes
along with the legality
of like the data
residency issues.
Are they really ready for
moving over to that next,
take that big leap, to probably
segregate the data and moves
part out of it over to the
cloud, which is what-- so
all these decisions.
We need to have a
holistic approach,
and that's what we
provide as a framework
through a heavily
[INAUDIBLE] approach.
Business application,
portfolio analysis that we do.
And then we come up with
very strong recommendations,
which eventually is up
to the client to adopts.
I mean, guided recommendation.
So in all this, like I
think Mike was stating,
the speed is breakneck.
We're not talking about
a four-year platform
or a two-year like
on a road map.
It's probably three months.
And you have to be very
realistic, because there's
so many options out there, so
many points where you can--
points of failure, so to speak.
So through this
entire journey, it
becomes very imperative
for our customers.
And that's what
they turn back to us
for is they need to have a
trusted adviser by their side.
And that's exactly
what we provide.
So we had, just as a
case in point, just
for the audience also
to know, we have about,
just taking the figures
recently with the last quarter,
with 26,095
successful application
migrations that we've
done over to the cloud.
And this is across
193 companies.
[INAUDIBLE], ANZ, and we're
talking the entire globe.
So we come with deep
expertise, deep experience.
We pretty much have a
majority of the questions,
even though the migration
methodology and the framework
itself is evolving.
They're very strong use cases.
And you can stop by
the booth if you want
some more details about it.
MIKE KAVIS: And can
I harp on one point?
MODERATOR: Please.
MIKE KAVIS: He mentioned
that another barrier
is that fear of lost jobs.
And what we really see is
when you go to the cloud,
you automate all the stuff,
you don't lose the job.
You let these people work
on higher-value tasks.
And that's something
they need to be told.
Because a lot of
the stuff they do
they wish they had time to
do these higher-level tasks.
And that's one of the
beauties of the cloud
is it takes away that mundane
stuff that you have to work on.
It frees you up
to work on things
that really move the needle.
So no one's job
getting replaced.
You're going to work on
more important things.
UDAY AYYAGARI: Exactly.
It's [INAUDIBLE]
versus context, right?
MODERATOR: Yeah.
So kind of to the end of
the business transformation
and the organizational
transformation--
to your point-- that
cloud's enabling.
There's going to
be customers that
are kind of on different ends
of the risk tolerance spectrum.
I think, John, you
were mentioning
sort of that choice between
lift and shift or new on new.
So what types of
things, John, are you
advocating to some of your
more conservative customers
who maybe don't want to jump
in head first from day one.
JOHN CROSTHWAIT: So
we still recommend
that they do think through
and have a deliberate
strategy and a road
map, even if that road
map is more conservative and
aligns more with their culture.
But a lot of places
they will start
is new on new is the easiest.
Where it's green field.
They're likely
consuming cloud today
in their interactive businesses,
whether it's mobile or online.
And then any sort of
major inflection point
in which they're
doing re-architecture
is an opportunity that we
encourage them to embrace.
I think the other
area, too, is SaaS,
which, when we
think of cloud, you
think of custom
development and the like.
But moving from instead of
doing high-velocity development
in the public cloud
with sensitive data,
which is where everyone
gets a lot of anxiety,
adopting SaaS platforms
as well as a way
to ease down that road.
And then the second is
we definitely encourage
them to adopt a platform.
When you at-- if you're going
to move at a very, I'd say,
more deliberate
or measured pace,
it's hard to bring
the organization along
if you just say, hey,
we're doing cloud.
Right?
And so, you know, here's some
broad based tools and whatnot.
But if you come in with
a deliberate platform
and also bundle it more
with-- not just, hey,
we're doing cloud,
but you're bundling it
with a different way of
delivering it, right?
And so it probably is
integrated with a number
of other initiatives
that you have in flight,
whether that's your
agile transformation,
or maybe you're
implementing DevOps.
And bundling that
together to where
you're bringing your
organization along
and this whole notion of,
yes, we do things differently,
and we're producing
different architectures,
and we're moving at
a different pace.
And if that is underpinned by
a very deliberate platform,
it's much easier
for an organization
to get their arms around.
MODERATOR: So, Mike, John
just talked about new
on new being maybe
the lowest-risk thing,
but also having more of an
organization-wide strategy
for cloud adoption and road map.
What are you guys doing
that's maybe different,
or in addition to that?
MIKE PEARL: Well, I
mean, I would agree.
The question is
not if, but when.
There's too much benefit
in moving and adopting
cloud for organizations not
to move in that direction.
And so, as John pointed out, we
do the same with our clients.
Be thoughtful about
what you're ready for,
as well as what
you're not ready for.
And we also encourage
people to invest the time
to really understand what is
the business value that you're
going to get out of it.
Because, as you said,
if you say we're
going to do cloud for cloud
sake, that loses people.
They want to understand.
If you can articulate the speed
at which teams can collaborate
differently across the globe
and compare current state
to future state
leveraging cloud platform,
or articulate how transformation
or development of technology
assets can go from a
procurement exercise
into months of development
to weeks and outside a month.
Those are the types of
things where people then
start to understand, OK,
here's the value that I'm
going to get out of that.
And then you're having
a risk discussion
on very different terms.
You're agreed that
you want to move
in the direction
of business value,
but you're thoughtful
about the risks
that you're willing to take
in moving in that direction.
MODERATOR: Great.
Mike, anything to add?
MIKE KAVIS: One of
the-- there's a lot
of areas to cover
on transformation
and organizational change--
one area that gets forgotten
a lot about-- a lot of
times it's developer-led,
so it's get the first app and
forget about the operations
side.
How do I run this?
How do I keep track of
costs and everything?
And in the data center, whether
your processes are good or not,
you know them, and they've
been in place for 20 years.
Now you're going to this new
platform, you don't have any.
Right?
So in the transformation,
we make sure, in sequence,
while you're building
architectures,
you're also building
out how do you run?
Look at the stuff.
So that's a big piece
that gets missed.
It's really easy to get
the first few in the cloud.
Then you need to get 1,000.
If you don't have
how do I run it,
it becomes worse than
what you had before.
So you've got to think
about the whole spectrum.
UDAY AYYAGARI: You
know, so the trend
that we've seen mostly-- so
can you repeat the question?
What are the hurdles?
MODERATOR: The question
is, for the more
conservative
companies, how are you
helping these companies
kind of adjust
to that clouded option journey?
We heard a little bit about the
roadmap, planning, the process
management, and so on.
Do you have anything to add?
UDAY AYYAGARI:
Mostly, like I said
earlier, there's fear and the
experience that's lacking.
So they don't know what
they're up against.
Even though there is starting
at their advisory board level,
at the board level, there is a
mandate to move to the cloud.
But they don't know exactly how.
So our approach, generally
we advocate an approach
where we just want to
move bit-sized steps first
before we make the big leaps.
So definitely, there's
no one-size-fits-all,
but typically we would go
through this entire portfolio
analysis where we do this
entire marketing of different
applications portfolio
segmentation.
Their recommendations
typically come across
in terms of what
other stuff that is
qualified for lift and shift.
And then lift and shift is one.
Re-architecting
and re-engineering
is another one where there may
be small tweaks here and there
that may be required.
However, that probably requires
some more in-depth recoding
kind of stuff, which is
a slightly expensive.
And there are applications
which you don't want to touch.
Just it's better off on premise.
And you probably may want
to think about sunsetting
those are applications as well.
So these are-- so just a
very interesting example--
we were working with a media
company not so long ago.
This has been there
since like the 1960s.
So there are a whole bunch of
code and COBOL-driven programs
which are just lying out there.
And when we actually engaged
with the entire cross-section
of the IT community,
half of them
did not even know what
those applications did.
So this something that-- well,
a typical answer was this
was there since I joined.
I don't know exactly
what it does.
And there's a fear of uprooting
that apparition because you
don't know what-- why
is there to be unplug it
by just moving it?
So there are some
eye-opening [INAUDIBLE]
which come as a part of
this entire exercise.
But the recommendation,
again, typically
comes-- there are
non-revenue-facing
applications,
non-business-critical
applications, that you want
to kind of put it on the side.
Just have a plan for it.
Put it in the roadmap
probably nine months later.
But you want to just address
the low-hanging fruit right now.
And what are those
low-hanging fruit?
Is there a typical
reporting applications?
DR applications--
disaster recovery--
which don't have a high
rate of [INAUDIBLE] kind
of requirements, even if it is.
So the idea is to have
adopters and evangelists
internally from
within the company who
can advocate for you.
Just a few successes here
and there and slowly--
and we've actually seen this
translate into mega projects,
starting with just moving a
few reporting applications.
So you'd be surprised.
Now one more point
that I'd like to add
here is-- the kind of
adoption that you'd
see within these
enterprises is exponential.
The graph is not
linear like this.
It just goes like--
it's a straight go.
When you're talking about
five, 10, 20 applications,
reporting applications.
After that they're just asking
you-- the conversation changes.
They're talking about moving
the [INAUDIBLE] applications,
[INAUDIBLE] applications,
auto management systems
which are directly
attached to the revenue.
And then the security
conversation starts,
because that's where the entire
conversation starts, right?
So the thing is, while we're
moving over to the cloud,
how can we change
our security posture?
It's not about how can I
protect my existing data
and move my existing
artifacts over to the cloud.
That is not the conversation.
It's mostly about how can
it change, because they know
the security person
that they have hired
is probably not the
best, and they probably
are two steps behind the
hackers who is trying
to break into the applications.
But coming with cloud, we kind
of make the point gradually.
Your applications are
safer sitting in the cloud.
And that becomes the
easy conversation.
So the whole thing
starts with wait
for the low-hanging
fruits, and then
making the conversation for,
like a few steps first, crawl
before you run.
MODERATOR: So it sounds
like the goal here
with these more
conservative enterprises
is to sort of generate internal
support for cloud adoption
through small,
low-risk wins, and try
to use that to grow that
engagement internally.
Now, we got a chance
to talk earlier
to Spotify and to Disney
who've, obviously,
been much more aggressive,
more progressive
with their cloud adoption.
How does that change
your ability--
what kind of dynamic
things are you guys
doing with those companies
that have fewer constraints
and are willing to kind
of jump into that business
transformational a
little more quickly?
Mike.
MIKE KAVIS: Yeah, well, some of
the things that we highlighted
here, the sky's the limit, if
you will, on what you can do.
Organizations that are
moving very aggressively
towards the cloud
and leveraging it
is-- again, the value that
they're able to generate,
and the speed at which they're
able to-- with our clients,
we focus on this concept
around high-velocity IT.
And it's based on cloud
infrastructure development
platforms that allow for the
leveraging a DevOps model,
that once you have the
platform in place--
and you highlighted from
some of your research--
this platform economy
that is coming up,
companies that start to move
in that direction really
start to realize benefits
maybe that they didn't even
think about.
You start to put
things into the cloud,
develop services,
develop solutions.
And as you continue to
move in that direction,
you learn more about what
you can be doing differently.
And that gets back to some of
our research on our CEO survey
where this whole notion of
providing the proper tools
to allow people to
innovate internally really
does change the game
for organizations
that are ready to adopt
it in an aggressive way.
MODERATOR: Right.
So John, Mike was
talking a little bit
about developer velocity.
We also heard a lot about things
like machine learning and data
capabilities.
What's sort of moving the needle
for your most sophisticated
customers?
JOHN CROSTHWAIT: So, let's see.
I think a lot of it
is about-- and some
of these kind of build on
a point that Mike made,
which is the promise
of cloud-- companies
go into it for a
number of reasons.
They feel like they have to.
They're looking for efficiency.
They want velocity and the like.
But the reality is
that it's really
one element of a broader
transformation in changing
the way they
deliver technologies
for their business.
And often it's driven by, maybe,
a couple of different factors.
One is that they need to keep
pace with the business, which
is now operating in a market
that demands a quicker
time to market, more rapid
and iterative innovation.
And at the same time, maybe
you've come to a maturity level
on some traditional models
of offshoring and outsourcing
and the like, and
now you need to get
that next level of productivity
out of technology delivery.
And so looking at a number
of different concepts
in high velocity, or new
IT as Mike mentioned,
really come
together-- really need
to be implemented in
aggregate to achieve
the promise of [INAUDIBLE].
And that includes platforms
in cloud, but also
DevOps and instrumentation
automation, and of course agile
to get into iterative
development.
And those three
together, particularly
if you're moving fast, the
only way to sustain that change
and not run into a
bunch of barriers
after your initial
sprint out of the gate,
is to ensure that you've
got the right op model.
And so you're constructing
your organization
to move with these
new tools and methods.
And for developers, it's
a completely different way
to operate.
So for engineers, you've got
to double down on the culture
and on the talent models such
that you can keep that pace.
But that's what we
found is that if there
is a lot of excitement, the
company has a strategy-- you
know, I think Mike's
points around making sure
that that vision ties to
goals that are measurable
and everyone feels
accountable to,
and then having this
comprehensive approach on how
to get there would be my input.
MODERATOR: Great.
MIKE KAVIS: So I wrote
this post on Forbes
a while back called "The Four
Stages of Cloud Competency."
And it matches with the old
psychology four competencies.
And at the first phase,
it's like you don't know,
so therefore you don't like.
So you don't know anything
about cloud, and it's bad.
Then the second stage is,
I kind of know about it.
So I go into it, and I
treat it like a data center.
And the third stage is,
OK, I've got competencies,
I've used the
cloud, and then you
start really taking
advantage of some
of these higher-level services.
And the fourth level is,
I'm totally competent.
And those are the companies that
are seeing the cloud as a way
to transform the business.
And those are like the Spotify
and those types of company that
say, I can use this in
ways and change the way we
price things that could
change business models.
I can offer services I've
never offered before.
And we've seen all those
types of customers.
And there's a lot of
different examples.
But really a lot
of how much-- like,
there's a lot of
companies coming
to the public cloud
for the first time,
but they've been building
private clouds for two,
three years.
So they get cloud.
And a lot of them are
coming to public cloud
because they said, that's
a lot of hard work.
I don't want to do a lot
of that work anymore.
So you get that mix.
The more experience
people have in the cloud,
the more they move
up that stack.
They start using these
quality services we saw today.
But a lot of the
early people are like,
I'm afraid of
lock-in, so they just
treat it like a data center.
And all they're really doing
is they have a virtual data
center.
They're still doing
all the same work
they did in their
data center, they're
just doing it on the cloud.
They're missing a
big opportunity.
MODERATOR: So,
Uday, any examples
you can share to Mike's point
of companies that have really
kind of gone to that next
level of abstraction,
really using the
higher order services,
and try to take full
advantage of the cloud?
UDAY AYYAGARI: Yeah, absolutely.
So most of my discussion
points would go around--
[INAUDIBLE] versus context.
We already know
about that, right?
So like points that
John raised about,
or he mentioned
about, DevOps, right?
So what we're talking
about the velocity
is phenomenally increased.
We all know that.
Now I'll give you
an example again.
We're just doing a proof
of concept for a prospect.
The core business model
centers around heavy compute,
heavy computing, right?
Now I don't want
to-- probably it's
fair to differentiate also
the other clouds, which is
what GCP brought to the table.
Is what used take-- the
complex algorithms that
would be fed into with
petabytes of data,
that it would just dig into and
then come back with the result
would take 45 minutes to an
hour for an average workload.
Now we just do a
POC where we just
got the same amount of
data and richer quality
with richer analytics
with under 10 seconds.
So this is just one case point.
So just think of the
magnitude of savings.
So we're talking 45
versus 10 seconds.
Now, that's not the
whole value proposition.
So, certainly, the moment we
just do this, the good news
goes across like wildfire.
Now they are not-- the
investors and senior management
are essentially
looking at how they
can scale this across
a vast portfolio
for their application.
So we're talking of significant,
enormous amounts of savings
for operation efficiency.
Now the Ph.D. folks
who are primarily
working on the core
engineering and coming up
with newer formulas,
so to speak,
without giving out too much
of their business model
and what they are exactly doing.
They are sitting side-by-side
with the folks who are actually
quoting it for them.
And the result
are instantaneous.
So we see the needle
moving heavily
in terms of operation
efficiency, it's for real.
So that's one example.
And then we have so many
different efficiency services,
[INAUDIBLE] being one of them.
And then we have the Vision API.
It just basically opens
more possibilities.
And then, certainly, we have
a lot of visualization aspect
to this entire
conversation that comes up.
If you're talking
logistics, for example,
we have a product for supply
chain visibility platform,
which basically brings all the
entire supply chain staplers
onto a common platform.
It's basically, we
track inventory.
Now on top of that, we're able
to bring in a very rich user
look and feel, a great high
level of user experience
in various different aspects.
So the conversation
has certainly
risen terms of the
capabilities that we
can bring, how we can enable
the business using more
enabling technologies.
So there are
possibilities all around.
So a lot of announcements that
we heard today in the morning,
they directly address how
each of these services
are greatly addressing
the business community.
So it's hard to say
there's one single area,
but then if you were
to speak about it,
it's probably the time
to market capability.
You have an idea,
bring it to the market,
it's a matter of
probably-- I wouldn't
say days or months or hours--
but it's drastically reduced.
So you have time
to market and then
operational efficiency are the
two things that come to my mind
right now.
But there are definitely more.
MODERATOR: Great.
Thanks.
Now we're starting
to run short on time,
so I appreciate all
your comments so far.
If you can give the
audience maybe just
one last parting thought on if
they're starting their cloud
migration journey, what's the
one piece of advice you give.
Starting with you, Uday.
UDAY AYYAGARI: Sure.
So one-size-fits-all
does not work.
Cloud migration has to happen.
OK?
So we've read enough articles,
enough material out there,
it's basically you want to focus
on your business versus you
want to be maintaining a
whole bunch of metal boxes
and then doing the
infrastructure kind of work,
right?
And still be left behind.
Now the transition
will be pretty rapid.
I think if you just
look five years back
where we were compared
to the conversation we're
having right now, it's
significantly different.
What I think is, along
the way-- I mean,
there are too many points of
failure, like I mentioned.
Purely because of
the way your systems
have been architected
or the kind of ecosystem
that you survive in
or live in-- probably
25 or 30 years old application
that's still surviving out
there.
It's time to do an overhaul.
So you need a trusted
adviser during this journey.
With us having done over 26,000
applications migrations, put
across all our
client base, we come
with a very rich methodology
and a framework to kind
of hand-hold you to success.
MODERATOR: Great.
MIKE KAVIS: Real quick,
because we're at zero.
Start with a proven methodology.
Start small.
Iterate, learn,
iterate, iterate.
MODERATOR: Great.
That's good.
JOHN CROSTHWAIT:
Quickly, then, I
would say, operate with a plan.
Create a plan that's integrated
with your broader technology
delivery transformation.
Don't forget model
talent and culture.
And the last is treat it like
the level of transformation
that it is and get
senior sponsorship that's
going to be visible
throughout the journey
to bring everybody along.
MIKE PEARL: Yeah, I
would quickly, say
touching on a point
that I raised earlier,
is this notion of it
is a transformation.
You want to bring your
organization with you.
So identify the
business outcomes
that you're looking
for and how cloud's
going to help you achieve that,
and that will drive a greater
willingness for adoption.
And I would agree with
John on this notion
of being thoughtful and diligent
about setting that plan.
Once you establish
your business goals,
be thoughtful about how
you're going to move
towards achieving those.
MODERATOR: Great.
Well, thank you all very much.
Please help--
[APPLAUSE]
MODERATOR: Appreciate it.